[Applause]
on a bright autumnn day A Familiar
yearly Journey for the British monarch
but in one place past a backdrop of
anti-monarchy
protest and for the first time in more
than 70 years it would be a King's
Speech not a queen's speech at the heart
of parliament's State
opening it is mindful of the legacy of
service and Devotion to this country set
by my beloved mother the late Queen
that I deliver this the first King
speech in over 70 years there was
interest in how a king who has Prince
campaigned on environmental causes would
handle announcing the watering down of
parts of the government's carbon Net
Zero
program this bill will support the
future licensing of new oil and gas
Fields helping the country to transition
to Net Zero by 2050 without adding undue
burdens on
households among the 21 bills set out
plans to toughen the criminal justice
system reform rules for land Lords and
renters and introduce a year-by-year
raising of the legal age for
smoking as the pump of the first King's
Speech since 1951 comes to an end time
for its content the government's
legislative program in the run up to a
general election to be debated taking
long-term decisions to build a brighter
future for our country with a
conservatives 20 points behind in the
polls and that election a maximum 14
months away the government is focusing
on its criminal justice reforms
promising Greater Community safety the
main opposition labor party has branded
the program gimmicks Division and more
of the same Harry foret Al jazer
London make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer